this is one of the things that people
are trying to hit the status on oh
you've been governor of Florida you can
handle the beaches and the Sunshine and
all that stuff but what is your foreign
policy chops what are what are your
foreign policy beliefs well here Tucker
I'm going to let Tucker do it himself uh
he read Governor desantis's full
statement on Ukraine with some
commentary take a look
and then maybe the most newsworthy
response that we received was from
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis DeSantis
has well-known views on many topics of
course but until tonight no one could
really say with Precision where he stood
on the war in Ukraine which is arguably
the most important topic in the world
and now we know
DeSantis is adamantly opposed to the
position that most Republicans in
Washington have taken on Ukraine
DeSantis is not a neocon who knew quote
well the U.S has many vital national
interests to santis rights securing our
borders addressing the crisis of
Readiness within our military achieving
energy security and Independence and
checking the economic cultural and
military power of the Chinese Communist
Party becoming further entangled in a
territorial dispute between Ukraine and
Russia is not one of them
without question he writes peace should
be the objective the U.S should not
provide assistance that could require
the deployment of American troops or
enable Ukraine to engage in offensive
operations Beyond its borders f-16s and
long-range missiles should therefore be
off the table
these moves would risk explicitly
drawing the United States into the
conflict and drawing us closer to a hot
war between the world's two largest
nuclear powers that risk is unacceptable
DeSantis goes on to oppose the policy of
regime change in Moscow which is very
popular in Washington and he points out
that the bite Administration has created
an alliance between Russia and China and
that's a disaster for the United States
so that's
desantis's position
clarified okay so before we get to the
nitty-gritty on desantis's position
what's most interesting about this is
you have to understand Tucker Carlson is
mostly an isolationist I don't want to
speak exactly for him but but he's more
along the lines of we should be caring
about Americans we should be caring
about the Heartland we should be funding
things so that people in America can
prosper the most that's that's that's
really I would say Tucker's reason for
being a public figure that is what he
cares about that's what he's written
about and talks about all the time uh
and what he's in essence saying the
reason he read that one the way he did
is hey this guy is not a neocon he
doesn't want to get us in these crazy
Wars what I also liked about desantis's
commentary there it was the most
detailed do not give them certain
weapons that could go on the offense
what have I been saying this entire time
throughout the Ukraine war every week we
give them more money we give them more
weapons and and you can see guys like
Lindsey Graham and Mitch McConnell well
this will help just turn the tide of the
war this will do it and it's like no
it's not oh we gave them four more tanks
they got a couple more planes a little
more cash that we don't know what
they're doing with none of this has
ended the war it has elongated the war
it has gotten us into a protracted
conflict that nobody knows how it's
going to end except the crazy guy on the
other side of the world does have the
biggest bomb and he has quite a few of
them and that is a problem so DeSantis
is trying to give a somewhat measured
answer there
[Music]
thank you